shut up
this is the sound of Chinese people
chanting for their ruling Communist
party and its leader Xi Jinping to stand
down these are momentous events whatever
this unrest leads to it is already
hugely significant not for more than
three decades as China's authoritarian
government being challenged like this
the immediate cause of the unrest an
apartment fire in arumchi in China's Far
West that killed several and was made
worse it's believed because of the covid
lockdown
but anger has been building for months
at China's zero covered policy it's
relied on lockdowns more than vaccines
and seen Millions stuck in their homes
for weeks on end
we've glimpsed out bursts of that anger
in protest but these have always been
dealt with swiftly by the authorities
before last month's Communist Party
Congress a banner appeared in Beijing we
need food not covered tests it read we
want freedom not lockdowns
now the same words are being chanted on
the streets of Beijing becoming the
slogans of protesters over the last few
days shouted at police observers say
China's government is facing an
unprecedented threat it's not a protest
at the Communist Party per se so say
it's a protest at mismanagement and
incompetence at the moment there are a
number of cities have entered into
protests
um if that spreads and spreads and
spreads well then you really have a kind
of you know protest infection basically
and that's really hard to deal with
the Chinese haven't come out on mass to
challenge their governments since the
pro-democracy protests of the 80s then
tens of thousands in cities across China
demanded more freedom and reform
this was the government's response
sending in troops and tanks massacring
protesters in the heart of their capital
at respond this time we'll be down to
this man China's authoritarian leader Xi
Jinping recently entrenched in the job
for an unprecedented third term
China's massive State security apparatus
is already in action trying to crush the
unrest but kovid is likely to spike
after this and the government's policies
to control it have failed if the
pandemic escalates unrest is likely to
as well whatever the government does to
try and stop it Dominic waghorn Sky News